I just threw the ball two entirely wrong
team right there
now hero is open I love his confidence
branch you can see he grabbed a rebound
to play before dribble down right into a
transition three back no hesitation
whatsoever 35% from three a year ago and
he picks off the pass 14 to 7 hero
pushing finds Robinson for three so
back-to-back triples for Miami
down a half minute wide open and that is
good from Charles cook and that makes it
28 2008 the long ball now hero into the
lane and the scoop nope hero stays with
it hero again and he gets it good effort
there by the first round draft pick out
of Kentucky taking 13th overall of how
you see the shoot until now hero finds
boyo how about Trey morning
other a minute it's all Miami Norwood 15
assist to turnover they are touching
fire here in Sacramento
now Hiro works on a low create some
space see I love that right there Wow
here he is again
oh good it's always right at safety
points that's his fifth three-pointer of
the game gets to step and Hiro will set
up a corner three pretty jump shot right
there good movement without the
basketball you know with you and I well
you know that's better than most because
you've gone through it nice lob in the
flush by Yount a matin set up perfectly
and Miami leads 70 to understanding
screen angles how did how do I help my
teammate and get them open that's a
better screen right there by say as Hiro
reaches up and knocks down the jump shot
here's where and as bank-shot know when
it comes out to them and hero steps in
front of the passing lane here he comes
with 35 seconds left a quick three and a
two-for-one situation now you take one
dribble to your left and shooter
contested shot when your teammate passed
you open oh nice Euro step movement
pretty finished by the rookie from
Kentucky Tyler here and McClain is
checked in for Golden State
he is from Belmont heck of a player at
Belmont here's the ball Ohio Valley
Conference first team player
good look by nun from downtown yeah that
is the guy right there that they need
the gig Dawn's a first-round pick in
2016 started his career right here in
Sacramento before going to Toronto and
there is the runner by hero this little
one to dribble pull up right there under
control warriors have 18 points off 17
Miami turnovers there's Tyler here on
pressure by Pullman like the fact that
Tyler hero accepts the pressure great
the room spins fires and hits tyler hero
pick of the challenge head on your own
bowman that's big that's a big-time play
by tyler hero you're gonna give him
scoring opportunities well 4 points both
from long on that lefty hook at this
miami coaching staff and according to
reports gonna be the jeely coach in
Sioux Falls for Miami as Duncan Robinson
knocks down from outside eternity a
pointer for the Miami Heat
great side on a bounce play right there
little flair screen off the inbounds
Robins get his feet behind his feet are
second well it should be fascinating and
it all depends on Kawhi Leonard and when
the decision will come down to be
minutes could be hours maybe another day
or two who knows tomorrow
Martin on the other end
[Applause]
Tyler hero you see where Chris Silva
came from though to rebound that
basketball Chris Silva a rebound
disappearance off of all three games how
a hero to a second defender what a good
pass that was a great pass
look the Clippers game much more light
Tyler here oh that's right zero up top
and this is interesting for me because
it looked like that oh that's a great
back cut lady right using hero to
initiate the office a little bit it's
worked but some guys just good things I
could say if they could make it work no
call there looks like he wanted wanted
the heater headed the other way hero yet
again will you watch Tyler here oh he
looks piled there you see it why he'd
catch the ball
recognize what defender is a third pump
fake step Friday wooden jumpers nice T
is already a promise
yeah he's already a pro he did you seen
with a nice feel great anticipation
that's the case you were Tyler zero he
has not yet signed his contract and why
that's is interesting fact you're
happier if they are looking to make
additional moves including it did you
see once again I know we're talking a
lot about here
[Applause]
the control hesitation dribble up top
sit up there easy dump for two will be
back I saw who has the ability marker
salt yeah
and so when you have those oh great
great finish great finish by Alexander
grace lake although by the Miami Heat
[Music]
nice rebound here Tyler Hiromi breaks
out nice passing done with the finish
here oh look at the finds its famous
tyler hero coming down the lane throws
it to silver going up top
last time i heard somebody say kid yeah
he was throwing me a lob also that one
time hello alright there we go now he
checks it well and then we see hero from
deep diversified portfolio showing us
everything his package communication is
key obviously the he didn't have that he
didn't have that communication right
there loud read to slide along the
backside here oh oh is that his direct
confrontational style rubs a lot of
people the wrong way you know using
factoids about Jimmy but you know it's
true Dan you think about the way it's
hero flown today this is where point
guards make their money that's pretty
good and hero bangs into three see this
is what doesn't Robinson makes an NBA
Letty's not MGM Park or the park MGM
where we're staying
yeah he was like yeah is pant big ten
network they loved uh Collins reactions
hero
he looks like a player does he play
tyler hero with 13 in the second quarter
you note the native language of belgium
belgium ins grade in on the delivery
from hero their sisters number one
all-time leaves for syracuse women's
basketball very nice for Belgians
Oh lemon very nice I got hurt a little
bit
I will played actually pretty good
without him he was a high volume shooter
he put in by Alexander this way Robinson
here get this thing tied up yeah instead
it's Martin on the attack playing it in
nicely fees for hero and it's a
one-point getting czar Jefferson off you
don't want to get you don't necessarily
have to get the ball you just can't let
your man get here I have to throw
outstanding highlight here on to make
this pretty good here watch you've seen
how many times we see draymond Green do
that right he just lobs it up a really
nice pass by Hiro Hiro is a very good
guy like a guy like that so just Pat
Riley serves Erik Spoelstra so does
Micky Arison it's the Miami Heat way and
Tyler hero who just ripped it away from
the Kobe's doing some things defensively
coming off pin down as you see right to
it
here's Hiro this guy feed the flame Thor
as you can see here he goes again put a
blindfold on this guy the rebound was
pulled by while or back to Hiro with the
jam on the assist by Tyler hero and a
12-point lead for the heat
what are you laughing at quran i've
always looking at the reaction to pat
riley air exposed to over here with the
Euro step to dump off two hands for
safety air exposure over here with the
Euro step to dump off two hands for
safety 14 points off of this heat lead
tower hero determine somebody drive to
penetrate corners filled and ready to
catch shoot
Laughlin was denied by Kyle Anderson who
did great job saving it what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content